hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast Graves disease assessment
current trends in Laboratory Testing I
am judia oror of labroots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labs.com the
leading social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by seans
Healthcare Sean Healthcare is one of the
world's largest suppliers of medical
infrastructure and is a leader in
medical imaging laboratory Diagnostics
and clinical it for more information
visit
www.sees.com
Healthcare before we start there are a
few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answerers welcome too you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if you don't
have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenter we are proud to welcome Damen
Gruen PhD pharmacist and specialist in
laboratory
Medicine Dr Gruen is a professor and
Associated laboratory director for
endocrine biology at St Luke University
Hospital and a researcher in
endocrinology diabetes and nutrition at
the Catholic University of louisan
Belgium was awarded the degree of
pharmacist and later of specialist in
laboratory medicine from the Catholic
University of louison in Brussels
Belgium Dr Gruen joined the Department
of laboratory medicine at St Luke
University Hospital in 2008 he has
published numerous articles in several
International peer review journals and
is also a member of the International
Federation of clinical chemistry and
laboratory medicine
ifcc communication and publication
division the ifcc task force for young
scientists he was the chair between 2010
and 2012 and now consultant a member of
the American Association of clinical
chemistry and member of the committee on
distance learning of the ifcc I will now
turn it over to Dr for his
presentation thanks a lot Judy for the
the very kind introduction uh thanks
also a lot to the organizer for this
opportunity to discuss with you today
about thyroid you can see uh my
disclosure
information and as JY mention we will
talk um today about a grave disease and
the workup of hyper thyroid cm and oh um
Laboratory test can assist a physician
for the the diagnosis of the of the
disease uh as mentioned by Judy I'm
working in Brussels uh Belgium so as
everyone can know we have a l lot of
good stuff in Belgium um this Europe
art in Brussels uh great football
players uh tetin te and we have also
there very nice products
fries chocolates probably some of the
best in the world and fries and beers
and chocolates lead the population to at
least more cardom metabolic disorders
and uh more uh risk for Health Care
disease eating too much chocolate fries
might be also a source of less iodine
intake and later on cause of thyroid
disease but
anyway um just to briefly show you the
place where I'm working in so the Clinic
University of s one of the largest
academic Hospital uh in Belgium um if
here you have the um Hospital facilities
and you have the the lab uh building
which is just there and uh we are um as
laboratory specialist uh devoted to
provide the best operation to The
Physician also more and more the uh key
advices for the the test selection and I
think that the the topic of the day will
be an illustration about the
the need of more interaction between the
physician and the laboratorians and also
the need for discussion between
laboratorians and manufacturers to try
to define the the the best um possible I
say fitting the the the expectation of
the
physician okay so let's move forward to
um IID see them um hyper thyroidism and
thyroid disorder more specifically are
major threat around the world you can
see that around 750 million people
worldwide are affected by uh thyroid
disorder among them hyper
thyroidism that's what we know uh if you
consider um brother view on the
community we know and that's the numbers
from Europe that
part of this styo disorder are not
diagnosed and you can see that the
prevalence of
undiagnosed hyperthyroidism in different
European countries is in between uh one
to to 2.5% which is something quite big
number so um as best and as early we can
diagnose that uh as best as the
physician can um Define
uh the uh best
treatment so
hyperthyroidism you might know what will
be the biological consequences as the
thyroid gland is working to I the
response from the thyroid stimulating
hormone will be suppressed and this the
in this case of um a lady 33 years old
you can see in the monitoring that the
the the TSH was
clearly suppressed and
uh the additional asset that the
physician will order will be of course
to to confirm the overt hyper thyroidism
by ordering uh free uh thein measurement
or freeo tyin measurement 34 uh
3t3 and you can see that there was an
acute episode there where the the
TSH uh drop was Associated to an
increase on the
T4 circulating concentration as well as
an increase on the T3 um circulating
concentration the question therefore for
the the doctor uh will be is this hyper
thyroidism a nonautoimmune hyperthyroid
ISM which can be a toxic multinodular
goor toxic thyroid adenoma or can it be
an
autoimmune hyper thyroidism and in this
case uh can we make the diagnosis of a
grave um
disease the first uh description of the
Grave Disease was done quite
simulaneously
two centuries
ago by the English Irish sorry Robert
James grave and by the German Carl Adolf
F basto and they were the two first to
um put a name on uh clinical symptoms
but the early first to maybe make the uh
thir description of grave disease was uh
what's called in the literature A
notable provincial physician sir calb
ilar and you can see among this patient
he was
describing five cases with EXO go in
1786 and Rel to enlargement of the
jugular Vents and some other sign
compatible uh with the symptomatology of
the Grave
diseases so uh as described by Dr grave
and
basto and um earlier we have related to
this grave disease a classical Triad of
symptoms which which are most of the
time the symptoms related to hyper
thyroidism and you can see around 19 90%
of the case will have these hyper
thyroidism symptoms of sopy will account
account um of 20 40% of the cases and
and clearly a lower percentage some
dermatopathy and less than 5%
um as you have hyper thyroidism in this
grave disase there is also consequences
related to the excess of circulating
thyroid hormone which can clearly affect
the bones the heart the liver and some
other
organs clearly uh influenced by the
thyroid hormone so symptoms clinical
symp symptoms clinical symptoms of hyper
thyroidism which can be nervousness
palpitation threating e intolerance
weight loss which are quite common and
not pathognomonic symptoms of grave
disease but that they have to be
uh collected by The Physician as well as
the potential presence of the thyroid M
uh and the the the
goer uh what will be important to
observe by The Physician is the presence
of an ofal opathy and the ofal
opathy qu can be quite uh
severe with a lot of um
symptoms
uh like the excess of tearing
irritation photophobia pain uh diplopia
and in some worse cases reduce visual
acity this ofal
mopy is related to uh the fact that the
um antibodies uh related to the D can
Target the TSH receptor which is also
located on the rro orbital
tissues um stimulating an inflammatory
response fibras glow growth and the uh
therefore the symptoms uh that can be
related um to the the pictures and
table um the dermopathy as I mentioned
is clearly less common uh and can
consist in non ping enema with radiation
color sometimes
pules um and usually located in the
pretibial region
um
is quite rare as I mentioned and
invariably Associated to the
opthalmopathy so therefore the physician
will collect all these uh
clinical
symptoms related to the
hyperthyroidism the clinician will also
uh be uh very
um caution in some specific cases like
the the
pregnancy uh the the the prevalence of
hyperthyroidism in
pregnancy range from 0.1 to4 per which
is quite a low number but in any case
the Grave Disease account for
85% of these uh cases and the uh
activity levels of the grave disease can
fluctuate um during the uh
pregnancy uh with exacerbation during
the first uh
trimester uh with more severe symptom
and the the Improvement
um by the delayed gestation so which
mean that when you have the the
suspicion of a autoimmune hyper
thyroidism in pregnancy or the the the
background of or an history of the Grave
Disease during the pregnancy you will um
select some specific test and if you are
not making the diagnosis
um
unfortunately uh the consequences of the
terot toxicosis are um in Associated to
an increase risk in the pregnant woman
of pre-term delivery
inin gross restriction and low fight
preclampsia also congestive failure and
FAL death so you need to
diagnose uh and make differential
diagnosis as early as possible to also
in this specific population uh have the
the best possible uh
management the the case of the the
pregnant women is also related to the
ability of the imunoglobulin uh
targeting the the TSH receptor to cross
the placenta and stimulate the the the
the Fatal thyroid gland
and we will have in this case fatal Hy
thyroidism related to the trans
transplacental passage of the the
maternal
immunoglobulines um so it is really
important for both the mother and the
the the the the child to get this
diagnosis and prevent all these adverse
con frequencies after the pregnancy we
will have to consider the case of um the
growing sh and the the the the case of
the Pediatric grave
diseases um as you can see the the grave
this is the most common cause of
hyperthyroidism in the Pediatric age
range uh must be um distinguished from
the other CES of t
toxicosis um and especially the toxic
phase of the Subacute or chronic lyos
thyroiditis um and the treatment
procedure will be
different what should be also noticed is
that uh for the Pediatric cases um the
clinical manifestation can be little bit
different or less pronounced and that
will be the the case of the extra typ
with all manifestation especially the
the the case of the um of theopathy
which will be less uh pronounce and
less uh easy to evidence needing clearly
um additional lap test
support so being at Cross holds of the
need to collect clinical
information um risk and lab test it is
clearly evident uh that in the case of
the suspected uh grave disease you will
need a
multi-disciplinary and teamwork
involving the
physician the thyroid Specialists the
team from the Obstetrics and as
laboratory specialist we have therefore
a key role to support them and support
the decision
through the uh reliable
testing the pathogenesis of grave
disease now as I mentioned is related to
the ability of imunoglobulin to
stimulate the TSH receptors as you might
know uh the
TSH is a glycoprotein hormone that will
bind the TSH receptor on the surface of
the thyroid follicular
cells the TSH binding its receptors will
therefore regulate the the production
and the secretion of the thyroid hormone
the thyroxin
trio thyronine which will
uh generate negative feedback system
involving the um hypothalamic pit
thyroid axis so the TSH receptor uh the
simulator of this um hormone synthesis
belong to the um G couple protein
receptor with seven uh transmembrane
domain you see on the table Don line
that the molecular weight of these
receptors is 85 kiltons we have 764
amino acids and the distribution uh in
the tissue who is quite broad mostly in
the thyroid but you can find some in the
lymphocyte fibroblast and
ocy uh the the function of uh this
receptor is the transduction of the
signal that's really important because
you have the as Lan the the TSH by
itself but also uh some other
imunoglobulin uh and in the case of an
autoimmune uh disease you will have uh
Auto antibodies
directing uh directed against the
um TSH receptor and that can mimic the
effect of the TSH causing an thyroid
over activity uh which will be
characterized by as I show you earlier I
circulating thyroid hormone and low
theum thsh levels um I will comment
later on uh but you have different kind
of imunoglobulin you will have um
immunoglobulines that can stimulate but
you will have immunoglobulines that can
also inhibit the um transduction of the
signal acting therefore as antagonist
that was is Illustrated in this SL and
some of the imunoglobulin will decrease
the response and will be Blocker of the
thyroid gland function
uh and the the pattern will not be the
in this case iper but hpo
thyroidism so um back to the the lap
test uh
portfolio uh and the use of uh um test
uh to identify this TSH receptor
imunoglobulin and you can see that
especially in Europe it is
clearly
uh in the practices of the the the
thyroidism
specialist and also the the the GPS this
recent survey uh of the European thyroid
Association show that
the the TSH and 3 T4 are key for the
diagnosis and the evidence of the
hyperthyroidism but the physician will
request more systematically the the TSH
receptor Auto
antibodies
uh as first choice for make the
diagnosis uh and that's something which
is uh also raising in the US country so
so you have uh in the laboratory test of
course first line TSH 3 T4 and you have
to identify if it's a grave disease or
not the auto antibodies and a say
looking for
um TSH receptor AO
antibodies they will be specific uh as
you can see uh the the prevalent
of these TSH receptor Auto antibodies is
around 100% in grave disease so they are
pathognomonic and they are clearly
clearly at low abundance in the general
population less than 2% and they are um
sometimes positive in some chronic
autoimmune thyroid DS but the the the
the the key words are TSH receptor Auto
antibodies are related to grave diseases
the clinical indication as I mentioned
are uh a lot so you have the
differential diagnosis of the
hyperthyroidism the differential di
diagnosis in front of an of talopa the
use of this assay in pregnant women uh
in child and try to uh and something
which remain discussed in the literature
the the the monitoring of uh antithyroid
drug treatment so we have a lot of
clinical indication uh and so we will
need to combine the efficiency and the
reliability of the assay with the
capacity uh of testing a huge number of
request so you have to select in between
the clinical you have to select aay with
I clinical performances and
asses with also High operation uh
probability
performances and that's what will happen
when the physician will make the the the
diagnosis back to clinical case
diagnosis and evidence of the it
antish uh receptor concentration
treatment and then the decrease and the
control of the disease so important for
the diagnosis important for the the the
monitoring of the the the grave uh
disease so if you go for a quick poll
what I did in my institution to The
Physician and check what they want and
what are they expecting from the assay
you will see that the clinical
expectation are from the the professor
dri the diagnosis of the Grave Disease
the monitoring of the uh
um treatment the the the
the followup of the the
pregnancy uh and what she is expecting
is a short turnaround time of analysis
to try to relas the use of um Imaging
and
craphy uh analytical
reability low cost and the specificity
of DFC be able to discriminate from
stimulating to blocking antibodies if
you consider the other opinion from Dr
Vanessa Primo for example again uh
indication for diagnosis the prognosis
expectation analytical sh General and
time of response same comment from the
doctor oralia alexu from our endocrine
division
diagnosis and ability to um sometimes
make the the differentiation in front of
of an hypothyroidism and analytical
command shortterm on time
reliability so what did you expect if
you want one day to won the cup and the
Champions League High clinical
performance uh able to have the uh
efficiency for the operation short turn
on time of analysis low volume of
samples required low cost and the
evolution of the assay and the capacity
to to be more and more
discriminant
so straight to the assay now the assay
for testing for thyroid um receptor Auto
antibodies has clearly have clearly uh
evaluate since more than 50 years uh and
we are no maybe starting the fourth
generation of aay
um the first first case was the
um uh naming based on the bioassay of
the uh long acting tyroid stimulator a
lot uh which was the first evidence by
this um culture assay of
the
immunoglobuline um uh structure of the
uh TSH uh receptor
stimulator
um the assays change a lot after that
and we are now facing different assay
and the
nomenclature is uh quite exhaustive as
you can see on the
table uh we can speak about TSH
receptors
um
antibody which can be confusing by
because indicating both stimulating or
blocking we have anti TSH receptor
antibodies TB y
y thyroid TSH uh binding imunoglobulin
you have also the TSI TSH stimulating
immunoglobuline so the norat can be
sometime Mis uh
leading um the the assay format most of
the current assay are uh a competition
for a lan so a competition for a TSH
receptor
um uh between Mark uh TSH or
imunoglobulin and the imunoglobulin in
the patient sample or can be
bio which will measure the bioresponse
to the imunoglobulin
uh increasing the concentration of
cyclic MP or the activity of Lucifer as
um the evolution of the assay uh was
especially trigger also by the
understanding of the nature of the
imunoglobulin and the ability to use
monocon hyoid simulating antibody with
the example of the M22 to compete um for
the TSH receptor uh and compete against
the the imunoglobulin in the patient
sample uh the competition format of the
assay is illustrated by the the the
response which is inversely related to
the signal so as much as you have
um TSH AO antibodies in the patient
sample as much as you are inhibiting the
the the signal and that's the the
principle of the the the the current
assay uh Eliza or
automated um currently uh and the
automated available on the market
Illustrated in this picture with the
rush um kobas uh trb aay or uh with the
crypto
uh track assay I have to mention that we
have also Eliza uh that can be the
example from
medip what is sure is that um The
Evolution allow us and the automation to
be clearly more performant for the
turnaround time of analysis reducing the
uh the time for respond and uh consum in
less bless than previously as you can
see also on the table the assay format
are different the
functional um sensitivity can vary among
the assay and the the the
standardization
um is uh at least the same but with uh
clear different in the absolute value
because of the assay
format anyway uh we can be ay uh because
the evolution of the essay was related
to uh improve clinical performances and
nowadays we are with um sensitivity and
specificity
reaching um 98 99% so that's a clear
progress also the benefit of the of this
testing term of cost
efficiency and uh that's studi done in
the um uh Us by Amy mck and Fred P and
you can see using
uh TSI testing in your
algorism uh will allow you to have less
time for the appropriate diagnosis you
will save uh money uh around 700 bucks
per person you will have uh fewer Mis
diagnosis you will reduce the number of
specialist visit and you will uh
increase globally your perform clinical
performances and
productivity that's the good news the
bad news remain Remain the high intermod
viability and when you compare different
method you see on the the picture um
from the study of massal that you have
clearly difference in absolute value
because of what because
of the difference in the assay format
the the source of the TSH receptor used
for the competition and the assay
procedure uh by itself so I variability
inter method there is a lot of effort
and Lind that Cho mentioned that in the
conference lot a lot of fav ongoing
laboratory medicine for the
standardization that's the case for
thyroid
assays uh that's the case also for TSI
assay with uh the previous effort with
the uh
standard
90 uh 672 and with the raise of new
international standard which will allow
more standardization for the aay and
less
variability uh why it is important to
work on the assay and to reduce the
variability
uh because we have to uh get the the the
best monitoring of the patient and
because the
uh I say might be specific for um the uh
Auto antibodies that can be stimulating
or or as I mentioned can also be neutral
or
blocking and we frequently can see some
clinical case where the patient start
with hyper thyroidism and you have a
switch in the pattern of Auto antibodies
and the switch will lead to more
blocking antibodies and uh more IO
thyroidism so if you have more specific
assets you are able to discriminate more
between stimulating and blocking aay
there is a way to do that and the
current way is bioassays and you have
commercial or omu bioassays and they
will be based on the uh ability of the
patient sample to stimulate in cell
culture a signal from the from the cell
line and they will be able to uh tell
you if it's stimulating or blocking the
matter of these assays um is that they
are uh time consuming they will require
sometime some specific facility train
staff so uh remain used by Reference Lab
um the Discrimination of using bi and
the Discrimination between stimulating
and um other antibodies can be important
because as specific as you can be um as
um relevant you can be in some specific
population that the case of the the the
Pediatrics and you can see a trend where
more
specific um
stimulating assay uh can have higher
area on the Rock curve in comparison to
nonspecific assays so you can have a
benefit in this population and the
benefit has been uh evident uh also for
the the grave orbitopathy when where it
can be um maybe more relevant to use
more specific essays so there is a
ongoing quest to uh try to be more
specific with automated aay and that uh
that's why um Simons work on it is new
ulite uh TSI ass to try to be more
specific and we have a clear new format
for the assay where the sorry where the
uh oops TSH receptor has been used in
theay has been re-engineered to remove
the part which is sensitive to the
blocking
antibodies and uh to only use the part
where uh stimulating antibody can fix we
are not in this case in front of a
competitive assay but we are in in front
of a bridge assay um where you will have
um a signal in this case which will be
significantly related to the
concentration of the imun imunoglobulin
present in the patient sample so you
will bridge and as much as you are
bridging with stimulating
antibodies as much as your signal will
be higher you can see the the the the
performances reported by the the
manufacturers we were lucky to go for
preliminary study here in brel you can
see here on your uh right hand side the
um Precision profile for a third
generation automated assets with
functional sensitivity around 8 you can
see here the Precision profile that we
determine in Brussels and you can see on
that the uh the Precision profile is
clearly showing
uh inter uh asset Precision lower than
four
per uh for Value which are clearly um
below uh
4.1 so compatible with a functional
sensitivity around um .1 uh
international
units we determine the concentration in
um fewt
volunteers and we were not able to
evidence the Pres
of to antibodies in these LT volunteers
so most of the LT volunteer free of
thyroid disorders free of Go free of um
family history of thyroid
diseases uh as value lower than
0.1 and um we add also step of method
comparison in
evaluation first we try to compare with
routin which is a second
generation
Eliza and when we did the comparison in
patient sample um we add clear
difference between the the absolute
value uh clearly indicating that the ass
format are not the
same uh so the the important phase will
therefore see how uh the U assay are um
performant in front of the different
subgroup and you have here the
performances of the Eliza second
generation you have the lower value in
the patient without grave disease the
highest value in the patient with
untreated grave disease and
intermediate uh positive value in
patient with treated Grave Disease when
you go in the same population you have
clearly very very low value in the
population without any grave disease
with the ulite the highest value are in
the patient with active untreated grave
disease and um I to intermediate value
in patient with treated grave dis so
meaning that the assay can discriminate
from non-g grave to grave
disease that's what is idence here in
the Rock curve so you have the
performances of the emulate assay for
the Discrimination of patient with
active grave disease to Patient without
any grave disease and the cut point is
around4 performances are quite similar
between the second generation and the
automated more specific assay but when
you switch and try to make the
Discrimination between patient uh with
grave
disease uh and patient without any grave
disease so grave disease treated or
untreated you have um
improv um area under the WR C in
preliminary study with a cut point of
three so the the the analytical
reliability seems to be rich as well as
the the clinical performances of course
the data should be confirmed by a
broader Court the common that I can do
is that we have of course discrepant
Rhythm you can see two of them here a
case of an um of the followup of uh
autoimmune thyroid dises in a lady uh
substituted and you see that uh we have
uh
um here positive value for the Eliza say
negative value for the ulite another
case lady with hypo
thyroidism um monitor for weakness and
which who will be substituted you see
the differences between the two aay
positive in one and negative with the a
with the an spe specific for
stimulating imunoglobulin
so this
discrepancies discrepant cases will of
course have to be confirmed uh by bio
asses quick comparison between the
automated assay available on the market
um and you see ulite versus kobas versus
crypto we are not modeling the same
thing so you cannot compare automated
assay among them and you need to define
specific cut point and specific
references for each method and monitor
your patient with the the same essay and
aoid switch in between the assays so a
lot of difference in term of uh absolute
value cut point so what will be key is
the communication with your um physician
if you are thinking to introduce this
assay inform them about the uh new assay
format the differences with the previous
assay and it will be inform important to
inform them about the the new decision
um cut points and the analytical
lmit so to summarize we are uh clearly
in front of um this ISE where we need uh
lab test for the diagnosis the
differential diagnosis of this over
hyperthyroidism
we need routin say we need enance um TSH
receptor Auto antibodies assays we are
still in the the need of more specific
assay which is maybe raing with his new
assay format uh we are uh still uh
dedicated to response to the physician
with short turnaround time costeffective
solution uh we still need to inform them
we we we still need to anticipate the
the change so we still need to play a
role of consultant in in laboratory
medicine and monitor this uh important
change so I would like um to conclude
now and acknowledge the the the
physician team in in Brussels Professor
D Professor met T Dr alexu and PR and I
would like to enl my colleagues from the
lab Professor WM v f Professor Mand lead
Teck for the the study benjam fasan of
course I will thank you for your
attention and I think that Judy will
open the floor for a question and
answer excellent presentation Dr gon
thanks for bringing that information to
us before we get started with all of
your questions here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us day questions can
be sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can first
question
is what is your assessment of the reason
for and the percentage of occurrence of
waking Eng Graves hyperthyroidism and in
Belgium in
particular this question from Lee
College
sorry okay excellent question I will uh
not have a specific answer um to to give
you uh I should need to be back to you
after asking the question to the to the
physician who might have um more um
data okay and there is you know that
that's an assumption that can be not
only related to the Grave Disease but to
hyper thyroidism at
large okay
um Andre asks another so you consider
testing for anti-tsh receptor ad both
stimulating and blocking the next test
of choice after testing for T3 T4 and
TSH is that
correct yeah that's correct uh because
we need first to evidence the overt
hyperism and the uh the the first
recommended Assets in this case are TSH
and then if the TSH is really go for the
testing of the 34 and then in a second
step you might want to go for the
differential diagnosis is it an
autoimmune or not disease and you will
go for the testing of the
immunoglobuline and TSI so yes there is
priority in the
algorithm if there are no more questions
I would like to once again thank Dr
gusen for his presentation do you have
any final comments Dr
Gruen
no I just would like to thanks you again
jie for moderating this session thanks
the audience um and I will be of course
happy to take later on question by email
uh or through the the the bio conference
channel so thanks again oh great okay
I'd also like to thank our sponsor
Seamans for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you today's webcast
will be available for on demand viewing
for May 12th 2016 you will receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on
lab.com you are welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next
time